i am pleased to announce
that president zielenski will address us
shortly
followed by speaker ruslan stefan chubb
the chair
of the radha of ukraine
and allow me also
to
have a special welcome to the ambassador
of ukraine and the ukrainian people
present in the plenary today
[Applause]
mr president
thank you
for showing
the world
what it means
to stand up
thank you
for reminding us
about the dangers
of complacency
everyday acts of extraordinary heroism
by ukrainians inspire us all
defense forces and citizens making the
ultimate sacrifice to delay
a column
of tanks
senior citizens standing up to face down
russian troops with nothing but pride
and sunflowers as their weapon
brave women
forced to give birth
in
metro stations
next to their kalashnikovs
they showed the world
that our way of life
is worth
defending
it is worth
a cost
all those who remember
living under occupation will attest to
that
all those standing up
in belarus
all those
looking to us
in moldova
in georgia
it is
worth it
for us
for the next generation for all those in
ukraine
and around the world who believe in
europe and
in our way
and for all those who want to be free
our european response
was on display over the last very
painful days
this must be
our whatever
it takes
moment
neighboring states have accepted
hundreds of thousands of fleeing
ukrainians
europeans sheltered ukrainians in their
homes
we have implemented a series of
unprecedented
massive sanctions
we have gone further and will provide
much needed weapons
to ukraine
we have declared that russian aircraft
and oligarchs private jets are no longer
welcome
in our open skies
we have moved for russia to be
disconnected from the swift system
we have banned
we have banned kremlin propaganda tools
european citizens organizations
businesses sports have taken a clear and
forceful stand underlining that they
will
not deal with
or welcome an aggressor and europe
stands ready to go further still
we recognize
europe's
ukraine's
european
perspective
and as our resolution clearly states we
welcome mr president
ukraine's application for candidate
status
and we will work towards that goal
because we will
because we will and we must
face the future together
mr president we stand with you
in your fight for survival
in this dark moment in our history
when you look to this european
parliament
you will always find an ally
a space to address europe and the world
and always
always a friend
this european parliament has a long
proud history of being a thorn in the
side of autocrats
and in this spirit i will seek a ban
on any representatives of the kremlin
from entering european parliament
presences
because aggressors
because
aggressors
and warmongers have no place
in the house of democracy
dear president dear members let me
finish out by stealth setting out four
important principles
for our future first of all
europe can
no longer remain reliant on kremlin gas
we need to redouble our efforts
to diversify our energy systems towards
a europe that is no longer at the behest
of autocrats that will put our energy
security on stronger footing secondly
europe can no longer welcome kremlin
cash and pretend
that there are no strings attached
putin's oligarchs and those who bankroll
him should no longer
be able to use their purchasing power
to hide behind a veneer of
respectability in our cities in our
communities or in our sports clubs
their super yachts should find no
harbour in our europe
and we can no longer
[Applause]
sell passports to putin's friends
allowing them
to circumvent
our security
no more
thirdly
investment in our defenses
must match
our rhetoric
europe
must move to have a real
security
and defense union
we have shown
last week that it is possible and
desirable and more than anything
it is
necessary
and fourthly
we must fight the kremlin's
disinformation campaign
and i call on
social media and tech conglomerates to
take their responsibility seriously and
to understand that there is
no